this week on quad Riga heroines
crackdown abuse of democracy Turkey's
Prime Minister rage if Talia parowan is
maintaining a hard line against
demonstrators who have been protesting
against his government since the end of
May in addition to the police the
government has threatened to use the
army to end the protests and hundreds of
people have been arrested in several
Turkish cities the Interior Minister has
warned that anyone who uses social media
to organize an unauthorized
demonstration will be investigated
Turkey's young urban population shares a
different understanding of democracy
than air21 and they feel their civil
rights have been undermined your host
this week Ali ashlyn hello and welcome
to this new edition of quadriga four
months from now the Turkish Republic
will mark its 90th birthday but few in
the country are in a mood to celebrate
as the anti-government protests have
revealed a great divide among the
Turkish Republic so the question is
where is Turkey headed who will prevail
in this showdown between prime minister
aired on and the anti-government
protesters that's what I want to talk
about on today show together with these
three experts welcome to South Harrison
Oh Jack who is an internationally
acclaimed german turkish writer and poet
he has written many books about the
cultural transformation of Turkey and
was a guest professor at MIT and
berkeley vintage ohrid worked as an
author and journalist in Turkey for many
years before joining the German
Institute for International and security
affairs here in Berlin is an expert on
Turkish domestic and foreign policy and
delay Khudobin is a columnist for the
Turkish news paper mill yet she's also
mercato fellow here in Berlin previously
she was a columnist for the Turkish
newspaper radical and has served as a
program director at the Turkish economic
and social studies foundation also known
as Tess F
welcome to your all troubling times in
turkey these days in deeds affair Genoa
jack turkeys very much in the headlines
in the international media and in the
international focus the police massive
police crackdown has been widely
reported on and it's probably has heard
the standing of prime minister aired on
so the question on everyone's mind is
shove their channel Jack and perhaps you
have an answer to that he must know that
his standing is being heard in the
process why is he doing that why is he
so uncompromising mmm this is a very
very question 1 million dollar question
i would say i'm not even sure if he
himself knows why he's doing that is her
concept for this policy turkey is going
for a very sensitive period of
transformation look the government
started a very ambitious a step towards
to solve the Kurdish problem and this
problem is going since 30 years struggle
in the country and it was such a big
step and it needed so much calm and so
much stability in in the country itself
in the society now exactly the opposite
is happening there is no stability there
is a big gap between the different
groups where is a unity of groups it was
not imaginable before far right and far
left a lot of extremist groups but also
a lot of young people who are globalized
who are modern who want to live in a
liberal open society and I have the
feeling this mr. other one cannot read
more the science of the time and he
cannot read more the science he he was
creating through his policy of
democratization to opening this country
it's a tragic he is a tragic figure at
this moment but on the same side he is
also not only tragic he is also a
culpable for all those police abuses for
the injured people especially for
the actor police acting towards injured
people towards medical personnel this is
not only political failure that I think
this has ridiculous expenses on the end
and indeed the police crackdown has been
massive up until now we talking about
55,000 people injured and at least four
people that the police has fired tear
gas not just in Taksim Square but even
in hospitals and the hotels and and
lawyers were arrested those who wanted
to represent the protesters and doctors
were arrested those who wanted to treat
the protester so indeed a very massive
police crackdown how do you explain this
go in telford I think what is what is
new is not the way the police crackdown
on demonstrators this we in a way
experience every oh we had used two
experiences in every first of May at the
same place at Taksim Square and the
areas around what was new for the first
time that it was really is it's kids of
these new urban middle flowers of
so-called white Turks we see and I think
that these urban middle classes
experience was the first time that they
themselves or their kids are subject of
this violence and of this confrontation
explained why there was such a big
solidarity with the demonstrators which
was for the first time I remember very
well the scenes when shop openers
accused demonstrators and handed it over
handed them over to the police but this
time it was quite the other way around
and everyone was not able nobody it was
able to force all this and delay cubana
it's easy to forget these days but only
four weeks ago turkey was by all
accounts a somewhat normal country was a
successful country Bob I if you will
economic standards these protests that
started on May the 28th started with a
few environmentalists trying to preserve
gezi Park one of the few green spots
left in Istanbul and this has turned
into a massive anti-government protest
did it have to come to this point well I
mean I think um
you know when we you right of course
four weeks ago things looked things work
on but there were already signs of sort
of things going wrong politically
socially in turkey i would say since two
thousand five six when you look at the
legal framework for example you know
we're now talking about the police abuse
affects power that has been made
possible by the new police law that was
passed in 2005 in 2005 also new criminal
law was passed in 2006 significant
amendments were made anti-terror law now
all of that created a legal framework
which on the one hand expanded the
definition of terrorism in a way that
made anyone and everyone who is you know
expressing dissent on any issue so
subject to the scope of anti-terrorism
and that had implicated you know
repercussions for the Kurds of course
you know as we say in the what's known
as the carjacker trial under which
thousands of Kurds are being prosecuted
hundreds of them still in prison for
years now including elected Kurdish
politicians the the the president of the
Nebraska football team also for example
was prosecuted under anti-terrorism law
and also made possible the police to use
this gave me the extraordinary powers to
the police now all of this since 2006 i
would i would say has started to sort of
elini eight and anger segments of
society slowly you know first occurred
of course because of the chi chi Chi
trial then find out about your fence for
example you know that also was very
controversial the prosecution and
imprisonment of the head of an aperture
and then and then various other things
you know question about abortion you
know the abortion debate Prime
Minister's remarks and attempts to limit
women's right to abortion you know think
and and then various various very
controversial projects of urban
gentrification now so things were
building up there was tension but what
but this was not foreseeable the way
that it would all of that tension would
explode like this was it was going to
maybe somehow
but what has happened was you know what
happened and I mean it basically
exploded with the gives of Park
incidents so not just one big issue but
while the few issues accumulated into
this anger that has if you will
evaporate it then and come to the fore
shine in light of the gezi Park movement
and de la cubana of course is right
after General Jack in that the cracks if
you will were already there a lot of
people were saying that Prime Minister
everyone in the party is getting too
involved in people's lives see I think
our own successful that he's coming from
an ideological background I mean we have
to look in this person who is this ad
one he's coming from the I become party
of the 70s 80s this was a third world
party an Islamist party a party against
the West i would say anti-semitic art
not only anti-zionist party and I become
cells was anti-semitic at his talks and
this was not a party staying on the on
the honor on a democratic basic I would
say he is coming from this formation
he's coming from this education and then
he started in the twentieth two thousand
years in the beginning of the two
thousand years a very new policy new
speech which was a very pragmatic and
now I think he is losing this pragmatic
ground he lost it already he's in this
ideological ground he he created in a
kind of new Muslim new speech and the
pepper and the salt of this new speech
this is the glorifying the Ottoman
Empire we have all the heroes from the
old turkish textbooks now on the places
are spoken out by the Prime Minister
this is very strange and I think he did
he didn't understand that the middle
class is the so-called why Turks the
sons and daughters of this white Turks
are not very similar like the parents we
had a connection to the big cities of
the world they are connected with to
wear a globalized we want to live in a
modern open society and the question is
now how react the central Anatolia
because
is the coastline the big cities how
reacted the young generation of the
center litoria young voters of our party
how are very dealing with this
globalization can make really
communicate with the modernity those are
big cultural questions nobody is really
discussing this real cultural oppression
is not only about the park and trees and
big cultural questions indeed and I
think we all agree that it is no longer
about trees but a way of life that is
being at stake in Turkey and let's stay
with the grievances of the protesters
here for a second gun terrified the
Turkish newspapers Armand just recently
published a pole and Zaman as we all
know not a newspaper if you will that is
highly critical or has been highly
critical in the parts of the Prime
Minister fifty-five percent according to
this poll are saying the government is
getting too involved in people's life
and by that they mean the restriction of
the sale of alcohol banning public
kissing and and so and so forth do you
think the protesters have a point
naturally they have a point or sure they
have a point and what is a big question
for me is if what what Zafar said how
are the reactions in the possible
electorate of other one in central
Anatolia but also in the big cities and
a little bit agree/disagree what what
you said that other one brought up a new
discourse of Ottoman strength and of the
authoritarian powerful state I think
right of the country that this discourse
exactly stems from the time of Arabic on
20 years ago 25 years ago and even as
the concept of Davao dolo a is good to
be traced back to that time but what is
interesting that said actual Muslim
conservative society of today in Turkey
has changed a lot when every one came to
power in 2002 and before he represented
a new urban Muslim middle class class a
new Muslim entrepreneurship he was in a
way in very close contact with new
Muslim intellectuals that had a lot of
product a thoughtful production of
intellectual production we remember the
contract of Medina contra concepts of
living together different
cultures differ different police
believes and we saw a climate of
Tolerance in these in these new
environment and what we see today is
doo-to's effects that Edwin now reigns
for 10 years and has get hold of of the
state apparatus he is now falling back
into an author retiring discourse that
is in my view not that does not
represent really a new generation of of
young Muslims and therefore it is
exactly what you said suffered the
question is now how in the positive
possible a bad one elected this is
perceived and the Interpol you mentioned
they had been an outcome that everyone
lost already seven points in of its
electorate I hope that this continues
and his standing is indeed diminishing
within Turkey and certainly brought
delay qurban but it's also true isn't it
that aired on still has a lot of support
he has support namely in central
Anatolia his support in the Black Sea
region he has certainly the support in
the more conservative neighborhoods in
Istanbul so Istanbul is not Turkey and
at the end of the day these pictures
that were seeing in Taksim Square might
be perceiving in that it it suggests
that the entire country stands against
him is that accurate well actually I
would say Istanbul is turkey in that
toxin doesn't represent all the Istanbul
be some was really a microcosm of Turkey
I was in Istanbul last weekend and
witness both the demonstrations at the
time still ongoing at gezi Park but also
saw the rap sword people both buses of
people going to the Prime Minister's
rally in that sense it does represent
the sort of the mixed very mixed nature
of the Turk of Turkey but you're right i
mean he does have still a big support
but he also built on a coalition of
votes so he take you know it's sort of a
KP is not a homogeneous party right you
have sort of shades of different
political ideological lineages there you
have heat gets votes from the
Nationalists you know the right-wing
nationalist he gets certainly of course
votes from devout Muslims some from
liberals
no sort of Democrats certainly from
kurt's developed cars etc the challenge
for him is now as it has always been you
know how to keep this coalition together
that's why when you look and this is not
the first time that a aired on Prime
Minister are done is sort of being
authoritarian in his discourse or
policies when you look at previous
elections municipal and national before
the elections he does that right and
then you know he wins the elections and
then he comes with this very sort of
leak conciliatory speeches of I'm your
prime minister of everybody going back
to your first question earlier is why
he's doing that we now have three
elections coming in two years the
municipal elections the presidential
elections and of course the general
elections it's not a sir we know that he
wants to be he wants to change the
system from parliamentary democracy to
presidential system he wants to be a
strong president the reason why he wants
that also is because in a way he trapped
himself to this situation where by the
rule of AKP the party has a rule whereby
nobody can serve three consecutive terms
and he's already had two terms so he can
no longer be Prime Minister for the
third time unless he changes the party
rules he doesn't want to as we say in
Turkish swallow but he spit you know
spitted so he wants to change you know
but presidential system that's not going
to happen that's clear now so therefore
I mean he's sort of he doesn't want to
lose the nationalist votes right and
then you know he doesn't also want to
lose the devout Muslims but as you test
that he is losing the you know liberal
votes and I think you know in terms of
you know your question earlier a lot of
people I believe and I see read that
there's also disapproval in his
constituency also in his base also but
will they change maybe not because
there's no they don't see an alternative
to him so probably he will win the next
election also and indeed 2014 was
supposed to be and by all accounts there
will be a very crucial year for promise
daredorm personally but also the party
you've mentioned 2014 and March
municipal elections are coming up in
Turkey in the summer the presidential
election was supposed to take place
before that obviously the change of
Constitution and the ref
random with the aim as the liquid one
pointed out of appointing himself as the
new president of Turkey do you think as
delay Quran has suggested he can abandon
abandon that hope of becoming president
I think adore is too early is it too
early to count about yes but I think
Iran is always good for a surprise we
shouldn't underestimate him the only one
way he has now i think is to make a very
big step towards a liberal constitution
it's the only thing he can do to bring
his position back into democracy because
this is what we are questioning now is
this man still standing on the ground of
democracy or he has another type of
Lukashenko put in like regime which feel
absolutely not function in Turkey and
this is the tragedy of strong leaders I
mean he's a charismatic leader and his
successful of course economically at
least but the tragic of charismatic and
strong leaders is that they attract a
lot of weak supporters and we attract
also a lot of weak personalities as
advisors I think his problem now these
days is his advisors I cannot reveal
really voices who say look we have a
more more bigger problem than only an
international conspiracy I mean we can
read it the situation like with the with
the theory and with the language of the
70s and the cold world war and so on we
can league read it like in a lot of Arab
countries there is always a Western
compress it reverses countries and so on
but it's much more complicated and we
have to we have to look really in in the
society what's going there and if they
will really look at the society the
language will change the problem is the
language of mr. adorn this language
doesn't represents turkey doesn't
represents whole turkey intensity rubriz
represents also the mood of the people
the style of the people and the
inclination for conspiracy theories in
Turkey is indeed quite white witches
primary
everyone is playing upon this when he's
blaming the foreign media is blaming CNN
he's blaming BBC Reuters not deutsche
welle yet that might change after the
show he's certainly blaming foreign
agents who are meddling in the affairs
in Turkey but let's get back to the
point which i think is interesting and
crucial has he damaged his reputation
and standing within Turkey to the point
of no return or is it as after chenoa
suggested we should not count the Prime
Minister out quite yet I would agree
with professional check we have seen
that he is a very pragmatic figure that
he is both driven by his emotions
somebody's sometimes falling completely
victim to his emotions but at a couple
of days he's able to really reshape it
for example with the correct we had very
authoritarian style rhetoric and
practiced Roberts occurred and a couple
of weeks later we have negotiations with
aired on every with a Jonin sorry and
therefore I would not be surprised
exactly what's after said when he neck
in a couple of weeks he is adopting a
completely new discourse but what I
think what is even more important I
attract your attention we are talking
about one man and that I think is the
bad thing in Turkey it's a real problem
17 million are looking at one man like
the rabbit on a snail and what we saw in
the protest it was the complete
dysfunction of a lot of institutions
first to press we solved it's a press
for a couple of days did not report what
happened and this tells us a lot about
the structure and the dependency on the
press on the government on different
reasons then we saw the dysfunction of
social d shiori there was almost no
independent or no investigations against
the brutality of the police without
having felt a content of the government
to do it yeah and when you see when you
look at again at the press the press is
fearing to be punished by for example
direct tax investigations that means we
have we don't have an independent text
ministry tax administration and you can
continue this tour tour to a lot of
things that means at what is important
for us as Europeans negotiating with
the it's not only the ZZ it's mood of
the prime minister or they also return
in style of the primary prime minister
but that the fact that the institutions
are not working to a large degree while
the institutions are not working to a
large degree says going to soy fat and
the protests that have so far cost five
thousand injuries and at least four
casualties are continuing but they might
be print in Ewing in a very different
way than previously let's have a quick
look silent vigils have been held in
several cities with people standing
motionless for hours on end in Istanbul
protesters gazed at a poster of Ataturk
the founder of secular Turkey the vigils
follow a ban on anti-government
demonstrations and a clamp down on
freedom of expression so you can't use
Twitter you know many hashtags were
blocked also sharing something on
Facebook is dangerous demonstrators have
also found another way to express their
opposition we're staging hero reading
protest my friend has been reading a
book here for 28 hours after the
police's heavy-handed tactics reading
books and passively standing in the
street are signs that government
opponents will continue to try and get
their message out
well delay qurban performance artist by
the name of air dam goondas started this
new trend this pacifists silent protest
movement if you will that has caught on
very quickly in Turkey and even brought
what do you make of this oh I love it I
think he's brilliant not just him I mean
from the beginning that gives it
protesters at gezi Park have been I you
know they were so creative they've been
using you know humor and Exeter that has
been much commented on but most
importantly this has been a very
pacifist very peaceful you know protest
which the police and the state in turkey
is completely unable to deal with they
don't know what to do with this you know
someone you know when he stood and then
you know he was soon joined by others
after eight hours or so you know the
police came and arrested them now on
what grounds obviously there there's no
legal basis for that right just like 30
plus lawyers were arrested when they
were the you know sort of making a
demonstration at the courtroom again
there's no legal basis especially to
arrest lawyers you know that it's very
difficult even under the turkeys quite
sort of authoritarian criminal law still
so it's just because the only kind of
protest that society and the state have
been used to it until today has been you
know sort of like people demonstrate and
walking on the streets marching you know
with banners and part et cetera and then
you know things turning violent but this
is something new and I it's just I find
it very exciting really so a new protest
movement which the Turkish police is
somewhat irritated about and it has a
tough time dealing with and coping with
but it was telling what one of the young
processor said mainly that even those
who are posting in social media are now
being following of course the social
media and Turkey has taken on during
these protests have taken on a much more
prominent role due to the failure of the
established Turkish media now you write
for one of the Turkish newspapers you're
right for a meal yet how do you explain
this utter complete failure on the part
of the Turkish media to report
accurately about these protests well
that has a lot to do with
media ownership structure in Turkey the
with the exception of a few you know
journal newspapers and you know
broadcasting stations most media
mainstream media in Turkey belong to
large conglomerates large holdings whose
owners have investments in various
sectors like the energy sector
transportation to resume etc these
people enter into public bits that they
get from the government right so which
then explains so they use the media
these owners use the media as an
instrument to sort of use against the
government if necessary you know or
alter and/or to sort of secure public
bits by being very you know
pro-government in their in their
coverage that's the biggest problem in
Turkey but this is also not new and the
use of social media is not new I would
just recall remind this incident in
December 2004-10 was that in robust key
in the small village in with the Iraqi
border as you may remember Turkish
military jets bombed and caused the
death of 34 Kurdish civilians it took
the media in Turkey even the websites 18
hours 18 full hours to report on that
and they did so only after the
government actually made a public
setting about it but by then the word
was out in the social media which forced
the government to do something about it
so the media owners you're saying
business interests predominate the
thinking not so much the accurate
reporting on the grounds which gives
social media of course if you will a
heightened importance but of course
social media is also a tricky tool
sometimes in that it's hard to control
for one but it's also hard to if you
will check the accuracy of the things
that are being posted what do you make
of this this absolutely right but you
know this is a global development that
social media is more and more important
newspapers are losing ground everywhere
and so I think it's a very bad sign for
Turkish democracy how ish media
functioning and this days but this is a
very old problem in the 90s it was the
same
it shows that a lot of things didn't
change in Turkey we have a talk about
democracy but for example the media
situation is very critical but I want to
to come back to another point if you
allow me I think the real question of
today is what's going on with the center
right and the turkey I mean it's it's
becoming more and more of a question of
values the Muslim majority of the
country has to deliver and this is also
your question how is how how are the
news accurate who is lying who's saying
not right things this is a value
question when prime minister says that
there was a mask ended where
demonstrators followed by the police
find refuge and they were drinking
alcohol there when he repeats this and
he cannot deliver a proof this is a
scandalous triche this is a scandalous
situation for every devout Muslim can a
prime minister coming from a Muslim
background lie openly to the masses this
is not possible and this is a very very
critical situation I don't understand
this is why I say this man has very bad
advisors around what those people think
how this pictures how is talking and of
course all the social media a lot of
irritations and allegations which I'm
not right are going around but the
members also not every member of the
social maybe as prime minister in Turkey
and you've already mentioned and you've
already mentioned the rhetoric on the
part of primacy erdowan if you will to
rally his more religious supporters
which begs the question because the
foreign media is reporting on a very
polarized country it is reporting mainly
on religious AKP supporters versus sex
or not right that was going to be my
question is this an actress is a black
edition so simple and we will see how it
will develop in the next years it's a
long process you know I think this is a
philosophical problem because if you
live in a modern world if you have this
big cities this Free Cities this free
style of life
if you come from a Muslim background you
have to arrange yourself with this new
situation this was easier in all the
times in this camera this regime you
know you were depressed yeah you
couldn't have as a woman the scarf you
were at the edge of the society you
didn't have the money power it was very
easy to talk about situation now it's
much more complicated now you're strong
now you have the money now you have the
center of the world everyone is looking
at you and you have to deliver an idea
in perspective a language which is based
and fitted by humanity by a kind of
democratic mood and also open minded
mood and this is not visible until now
really so not as black and white as some
of the media might want to portray the
two camps that are battling each other
on the street going to enjoy fat the
question now is the political
alternatives in Turkey next to the AKP
has already been alluded here in the
round the coalition I'm sorry the the
opposition rather is very weak in Turkey
the JRP is very weak so is the
Nationalist Party the maap do you think
that a political movement might come out
of this emerged out of these protests as
an alternative to the AKP that's nobody
can say this until today or today but I
think what do what I said about that the
opposition is not really attracting
people is one of the points I missed
when I talked about the weakness of
institutions because even after these
demonstrations there is no inclination
now to engage in the PK in zg in the GHB
in the Republican People's part is the
biggest opposition party or into the
Nationalist Party and the only part is
that might on the owner on a middle
ground profit is maybe the pro-kurdish
party of peace and democracy as a midi p
which in my view did very successful act
very successful at the beginning
standing back because the Kurds didn't
want a weakness of the aired one
government who is negotiating with agile
on and who are very scared
that as a destabilization of add one
will put out all we will decline
critically decrease his power really to
handle the peace process but after
having been accused by liberals not to
step into the fight for more democracy
they supported they supported the
demonstrations and particular some of
the members of parliament of these party
played a very leading role and therefore
I think for the first time the Kurdish
movement really opened up to democratic
demands of larger part of society and
this is I think a very positive
development but I think there is also
the possibility that on the breeding
ground what I think what really is
missing on Turkey Liberal Party that
might not be really huge by the parties
that really puts on a version of center
right yes in Turkey everything is a
question of cyanide it's a big questions
may if I'm a big majority of one until
now the cause of the demonstrations has
in a way reproduced the old clash
between the coronation the Muslim Turks
on a way conservative checks which are a
majority of society and the other parts
of society which are a number and
numeral minority see the urban the urban
kimber lists the secularists the aloe
whites and all these smaller groups from
Christians to a cds and these now until
now this was reproduced hisses clash and
now the question is exactly what surface
of what server was in how are the
liberal of the more rational parts of
the Muslim conservative population for
businessmen the intellect see writers
how are they going to deal with it and
will they found some common ground with
the other part and I grew up on another
important question my pay what is
happening within the AKP what is
happening within the party a lot of
people are looking towards President
Abdullah who for instance who seems to
be at for the time being at least the
more reasonable voice if you will do you
think how likely do you think there's
going to be a crack within the AKP
party in that another movement out of
this party might might emerge well I
mean I think you know for a while I've
been thinking and I still hold that
thought that we will see something
parallel to what has happened before you
know AKP coming out of the welfare party
I think eventually something similar
will happen there were already attempts
towards that unsuccessful the
alternative to AK people still come from
the Muslim majority and possibly from a
KP so far the only real critical voice
which who's there outspoken it's been
the former minister of culture who had
actually opposed to God gezi Park
project and many other through these
crazy projects of the Prime Minister
including the third bridge big mosque on
charger etc and he's you know he even
organized a press meeting yesterday and
then two more members of the parliament
from AKP also spoke out one of whom is
an LED it's for president goon you know
he and Vice Prime Minister blunt orange
have been very much praised rightfully
so to a certain extent i would say i
mean certainly they are you know much
more compared to the Prime Minister
pretty much any every politician now is
much more sort of mild and setting their
tone is nice but when you look at you
and even oranges apology was very
unsubstantiated that was an apology that
still he said I apologize we apologize
but it was not based on truth and
justice you know it was there it was
still based on distortion of the fact
that the police it was they were still
you know defending the police even
President cool did that and he has
changed his rhetoric after Prime
Minister came back to Turkey from Middle
East so I mean I don't see much
difference in terms of their substantive
you know ground in terms of what's going
to happen it's very early to say because
part a lot of this is psychology and
social psychology I mean to try to
understand a prime minister I mean I
think a lot has to do with his own units
of psychology he really didn't expect
this he'd see this as a threat an
existential threat to himself and he
makes always references to 2007 when
there were coup attempts and how he
cannot read what's going on you know but
there's also social psychology
in that on both sides you know the
Muslims be you know the sort of the base
of a KP they are worried that that you
know pro coup you know the sort of the
pro military people will again topple
this government but on the other hand
the protesters and the segments of
society that they represent you know the
Kurds Olivia's liberal etc they also
feel you know this is an outburst of
this feeling of exclusion that has
continued for a long time that you know
the feeling there is my voice is not
being hurt and this is too much you know
and I the turkey that I mean certainly
the sort of to read polarization between
the religious and secular it's a bit
easy reading but I see a very polarized
Turkey and that's that's what I saw last
weekend when I was there and that I find
very disconcerting indeed disconcerting
a polarized Turkey but I think one thing
they all have in common in Turkey nobody
wants to see the military step in once
again after it has done so three times
in the last century in nineteen sixty
seventy one and eighty i think and the
billion dollars the Deputy Prime
Minister threatening to to send in the
army to call the protest is a bit of an
irony it's the same army that the AKP
has successfully managed to keep out of
politics but I want to get get to an
important point Zathura shano jug and
perhaps one of the crucial questions
that emerged out of this conflict namely
a lot of people are saying the conflict
the protests also are a very positive
sign it's a sign of the maturing of
Turkish civil society they're saying
it's going to strengthen public opinion
in the long run public opinion the
opinion on the people of the street is
going to become much more important from
now on many people are saying this might
be the end of paternalism in Turkish
politics would you agree I absolutely
agree i imagine if this protest were not
going on and Aragon was going on with
his one-man policy he will decide how
the Centers of the cities are arranged
he will decide where musk is built he
will decide what kind of art is good he
will decide what kind of cereals and
television are good or bad what kind of
country is this this is not a turkey and
which majority majority of Turks want to
live and this is also not the turkey of
the center right I think this is a this
is this is a point where mr. Elden we
nearly come to an end that he can see
that he is very charismatic he has a lot
of followers there's a lot of heart
lovers because they has this emotional
rhetoric but in an irrational look on
his policy he has to integrate these
different parts of take a turkey he has
to integrate the LEDs he has to
integrate the Kurds he has to interact
the liberal / persons and of course his
voters to the world Muslims and it is
possible there are Turkish we were
Turkish polish politicians before mr. al
de ho who were successful business one
is to goethe za it's very interesting
that his name is coming up and up again
in this days also from dan supporters
but they have to deliver that they are
really in this in this line and they are
not only alight with Muslim brothers
with Hamas with groups in Pakistan or in
Malaysia we are looking to them to the
east and they have also totally
forgotten that we are part of the West
this is not a line for Turkish policy
for the future why do you think
something positive will come out of this
oh it has come out already the
possibility to work together for all
these different groups who had really
opposed each other kemah lists and kurds
for example other whites and muslims and
we had some mustn't grouped into insides
of demonstrations also but i think what
is also important what what suffer said
that turks are in a way remembering how
important the anchorage in the West are
in the West is because particular in in
in in I think in the Kurdish move but
also in the kemah list and urban
movement there was a big disappointment
true and justify disappointment about
the bad relations with Europe about to
stall membership process and the danger
that I see now today that due to the
fact that aired on showed how
authoritarian his government is
the EU is now considering considering
even to slow down the membership process
and even more and what we see now we
should be happy that we have now again a
society that is longing for European
norms that is longing for more
democratization and we should try to
keep our connections with these part of
society and to expose pressure on the
government while the protests have been
going on for three weeks now in Turkey
and by all accounts they will continue
to continue they will continue to go on
for some time to come we will all
observe and continue to monitor the
situation of course in Turkey and
perhaps the protesters will get their
voice heard when election during
election time in 2014 I want to thank my
guests for their insides I want to thank
you out there for tuning in and looking
forward to seeing you again next week
for a new edition of quadriga